tu m'avais dit un jour où on était tous
les deux avec une copie de coupe de
champagne de mon bureau tu m'avais dit
peu importe les erreurs il est tout pour
moi je suis tout pour lui on se quittera
jamais ouais j'étais devenu un peu sa
meilleure amie son frère sa sœur sa
femme son Best Friends sa mère je l'ai
beaucoup soutenu sur la fin parce qu'il
était il est mort le 8 décembre ouais
j'ai pas envie de parler de ça
on parle de ça après ce que je pense
c'est make-up qui parle ouais c'est trop
compliqué tu sais mon chou j'arrive là
justement Los Angeles hier soir donc en
plus le décalage etc j'ai passé un mois
le plus difficile de toute ma vie
j'imagine j'ai pas envie de parler de ça
on parle de ça alors est-ce que je peux
sortir une jolie phrase de Beaumarchais
on n'est jamais ridicule quand on est
sincère donc de toute façon si tu devais
pleurer dire quelque chose ou quoi ou
nana tu sais je vais te dire c'est le
seul moment où donc je dis juste ça je
te regarde pas dans les Yes il est mort
le 8 décembre d'un d'un cancer
juste ça faisait longtemps qu'il était
malade ça a été soudain ou tu t'es fait
un petit peu non pas du tout c'est
arrivé en 4 semaines ça a été soudain
et j'étais assez fier de moi parce qu'à
chaque fois j'ai j'étais assez
clairvoyante je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe à l'estomac qui a
vachement gonflé comme un comme un comme
une sorte de de ballon de rugby en vrai
il me dit non mais c'est parce que tu es
pas là j'arrête pas de boire du
Coca-Cola et je mange plein de chocolat
mais je dis pas du tout j'espère que
c'est pas un cancer je m'étais pas
trompé j'espère que c'est pas un cancer
du pancréas puisque c'est quelqu'un qui
qui buvait mais qui ne buvait plus
depuis 4 ans donc je l'ai amené chez le
docteur qui est juste en bas de chez moi
on a fait un un scanner aux Etats-Unis
il faut savoir que c'est pas comme chez
nous ça prend énormément de temps on en
a pour 7 huit à 7 à 8 jours pour avoir
un résultat pour un scanner et ensuite
il faut refaire un autre scanner et là
on m'a dit c'est juste une tumeur il a
refait lui faire un autre scanner et là
on m'a dit c'est un colon casque cancer
first grade au niveau 4 et on va
commencer la chimio on a eu le résultat
le 3 il est décédé le 8 donc c'est
arrivé malheureusement en 4 semaines
juste comme ça du jour au lendemain
comme un mauvais sort en fait c'est
incroyable c'est c'est extrêmement
pratique
bien sûr tu as même pas fait le pardon
mais juste
tu étais là-bas avec lui aussi
la fille Turner aujourd'hui elle a envie
de quoi de se ressourcer peut-être en
France dans son pays de rester là-bas de
je sais que c'est un peu soudain mais
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as pu quelque
part tu repères sa maman est en Suisse
lui et lui est parti c'est est-ce que ta
vie est toujours là-bas est-ce qu'elle
est en France est-ce que c'est peut-être
pas le moment aussi je te le dis avec
beaucoup de sincérité de rester là-bas
non pas de rester là-bas peut-être de de
montrer autre chose tu as toujours fait
le show est-ce que c'est pas le moment
peut-être c'est pas ça je me suis j'ai
fait tout pour lui de A à Z façon depuis
17 ans j'ai toujours continué à
m'occuper de lui là j'ai fait tout de A
à Z c'est-à-dire aux États-Unis c'est
compliqué de sortir un corps de la mort
de de faire les papiers de de faire
l'enterrement de trouver l'endroit de
c'est très compliqué ça a pris un mois
les gens n'imaginent pas en France c'est
beaucoup plus rapide il est décédé le 8
et on a fait le la finale le 4 le 4
janvier donc tout ça je l'ai fait seul
sur mes petites épaules à moi c'est
tragique c'est dur donc je me suis cassé
de la maison c'était mieux mais comment
tu te projettes aujourd'hui
juste de pas pouvoir de pas être à Los
Angeles et pas rester dans la maison de
travailler tout simplement pour oublier
mais où tu veux travailler où j'ai pas
envie de j'ai pas envie de pleurer
alors moi je perd beaucoup hein
moi je pleure je veux bien monter
non mais c'est voilà faut savoir aussi
que j'ai trouvé son frère
mort
c'est c'est compliqué ton frère c'était
celui-ci je crois c'est ça
ça fait beaucoup elle est dure la
famille Turner c'est très très dur le
nom Turner se paye ouais et c'est toi
qui avait découvert son frère qui a des
suicidé et tu portais un peu tout le
monde alors que toi déjà tu as une
histoire ou quelque part faut aussi te
donner un peu parce qu'on t'a beaucoup
pris est-ce que tu as parlé à sa maman
qui est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'elle est
aujourd'hui dans une clinique je ne
dirai pas où parce qu'elle est un peu
fatiguée
je lui ai parlé quand elle était
c'est quelqu'un qui a des des problèmes
médicaux donc je peux pas m'avancer plus
parce que vous êtes dit c'est pas une
copine c'est c'est la famille donc je
dois respecter sa privacie etc parce que
voilà je peux pas en dire plus
malheureusement